abone ol
mi
[Alkış]
Evet herkese merhaba bugün çok güzel
anlamlı değil tema ile bir aradayız
Sizlerde
Ee Hayaller
fikirler hayalleri değiştirir bana bu
defa altında bir konuşmam yapmak
istemiyorum Bu teknikle geldiğinde
kendi araştırmalarıma bu konuda
teorileri ve kendi Hayat deneyimi
düşündüğünde şöyle bir konuşma yapmaya
karar verdim evet fikirler var yani
şekiller Bir şekilde bize dokunuyor
hayatımızı girip çıkıyoruz bize girip
çıkıyor Ancak her fikir zihnimizi tutup
kalmıyor yani bazı fikirler
bazı fikirler Yarışıyor bizi motive
ediyor Biz harekete geçiriyor Ama bye
her yer Sadece gelip geçiyor yani onlar
da bir şey
gerçekleştirebiliyoruz ben şimdi bugün
sizlere hangi fikirler Aslında
değiştirme ve dönüştürme gücüne sahip
yani ülke Çünkü her şekeri aynı Hoca
aynı kuvvete sahip değil görüştürme
birleştirme gücüne sahip olan
fikirlerini özelliklerinden bahsetmek
için gideceğim
dönüşüm
[Müzik]
değiştirdiğimizde belirlediğiniz
şifreler Her şey bir fikri bir hayali
bir hediyesi her
konuşmamda fikir ve Hedef kavramlarını
beraber kullanacağım Bizim işler
değiştirdiğimiz ve benimsediğimiz
fikirler değiştirme ve dönüştürme gücüne
sahip oluyor bunları ishal geçirdiğiniz
zaman benimsediğini zaman ucunda yer
alıyorlar ve yani mesajlarda zorla da
yapılan haberlerin evine gitmek için
ödül kazanmak veya yakadan atılmak ya
bildiğiniz bize yapışmış olan yine
bilmiyor Bunlar bizim fikirleriniz
oluyorlar buradaki ve bizi bütün ister
kaynaklarımızı aldığımızı zekamızı
bir düşün Saat faaliyetlerimizi Akıl
yürütme becerisi Herkes bu kaynağımızı
herkesi güzel olur
harekete geçiren
[Müzik]
zamanda bu hedefler bizim temel
ihtiyaçlarını karşılıyorlar bunları da
biraz daha detaylı olarak anlatacağım
son olarak Evet fikirlerimiz var yani
ilişkiler çok heyecan verici ilk başta
bir kere gelir heyecanlandırır fakat biz
bunun iyi bir şekilde planladığımız
Duran olmasın ulaşacağımızı orada var
olan hedefleri nasıl varacağımız pil
anlamadığımız ve bu yolda
planları sağlam ve dirayetini adımları
atmadığını sürece bu fikirlerinde bu
boşalması ve bir süre sonra sönmesi ve
harekete geçirme kuzeni kaybetmesi söz
konusu şimdi bir fikrin hedefini
içselleştirmesi da ve beni sevmesin den
bahsederken ve den bahsediyoruz aslında
bir fikir ve ilişkinizi söyle olabilir
fikir veya Hedef bizim dışımızda dır
Yani onun bir cezadan Kaçmak için veya
bir ödülü ile ulaşmak için ona sahibiz
birçok çalışmak davranışı bir örnek
vermek istiyorum çalışma Fikri
çalışmanın anlamı video nedir bizim için
önemlidir Eğer
bu hiç bizim dışımızda yoksa bir öğrenci
düşünelim sürekli dışarıdan çalışması
gerektiği ona vurgulanıyor sabu Hedef
olarak önüne kuruyorsa Ama neden
çalışması gerekiyor zaten sevmediği bir
konu olabilir veya iş yerinde bir
çalışan söz konusu olabilir Ona bir
görev verilmiş olabilir ama bu Görevin
anlamı neye hizmet ettiğini onu
açıklanmıştı bu Hedef Onun dışında kal o
gidecektir o onu buna işlem olmamıştır
Bunu sadece dediğim gibi cezadan kaçmak
veya ödedin omuzunda nasıl bir ödül
varsa bunu kazanmak için
gerçekleştirecektir Hedef burada kişinin
dışındadır Bir sonraki aşamada hedefe
içimizde olabilir ki içimizde olabilir
ama bu sefer bu hiç dışarıdaki başka
yöne içimizdeki bir baskı olarak
faaliyet gösteren edip yapmalıyım öyle
yapmalıyım çalışmalıyım şu bitirmeliyim
yapmak zorundayım yani Bu zorunluluk ve
yapmalıyım baskısı bu sefer Bizim kendi
işinizden ve çalışmaya devam eder bu da
yine Aslında o fikirden un ve o hedefe
yönelik olarak attığımız adımlarda
alacağınız keyfi Dolayısıyla
bunun da bununla beraber Göstereceğim
size almazsa kalitesiz de olumsuz yönde
eliyle
cezaya niçin olduğu zamanda 30 O da
doğru yapmadığımız zaman çalışmadığınız
bir performans göstermediğiniz var o
geçeceğim suçluluk duygusundan parçaya
çalışıyoruz biz bu aşamada çalışmak
benim için
anlamını almamışız bunu bir yer vermişiz
neden
her zaman Yaptığımız her şey çok keyifli
olmayabiliyor yerden çalışmak dersleri
daha daha iyi oluyor onlardı ama
bazılarını birazdan zorunluluk sebebiyle
yapıyoruz işte yardımda da öyle
yaptığımız bazı işler daha keyifli
onlardan severek yapıyoruz ama bazı
başka işleri de biraz sorun olduğu için
yürekten olduğu için yapıyoruz ama
bunların neden olması gerektiğine de ona
yapılması çalışması gerektiğini
anladığımız zaman birisi anlattığı
zamanda bu üzülürüz olabilir
söylediğiniz olabilir ve işimiz Olabilir
olabilir
bu ettiği zaman onu kabul etmiş oluyoruz
ben onu yapma konusunda güzel göstermiş
oluyoruz bugün çok anlamlı bir şey var
Her insan bir
insan rasyonel bir varlık yani yaptığı
işi nedenine anlamaya hak ediyor
Dolayısıyla açıklama yapılması bir
insana görebildiğiniz var ondan bir şey
istendiği zaman onun Bunu ister
değiştirmesi bunu severek yapabilmesi Ve
sonunda da bir performans göstermesi
için son derece önemli bir aşama Bir
sonraki aşamada ise bunu bir daha bir
sürü Evet çalışmak Benim için anlamlı
bunu yapmak benim için anlamlı kendimi
ifade artık özdeşleşir ben bunu ben
çalışma canım Geldi mi böyle tanımıyorum
bugün Çizimi çok önemli parçası artık
onu da ben özdeşleşir bu Dolayısıyla
çalışmadan düzenlenen ve ona ne kadar
özdeşleşmiş sen bunu ne kadar değilim
Sen ise modamız göstermem onu Ne yapmam
çalışmaya başlamak için göstereceğim ya
demişti o kadar kuvvetli oluyor şimdi
hedeflerimiz benimsediğimiz var
gelmişsiniz kar değiştirmeden bahsettik
onu bir değer olarak Kabul ettiğinde bu
fikri bu hedefi bir değer olarak Kabul
ettiğinde onlara özel size artık içine
yerleştireceğiz o ben oluyorum Bugün
size bütün kaynakları gelmişti vurgusuna
Kaynar düşünüyorum kaynak video böyle
bunu yaparsan söyledim cezalısın bunu
yaparsan şöyle bir uzanırız Bu fikir
benim sen de benim için yerleştiği için
artık böyle onu ödülü de zaten Bilim ama
gerçekleştiriyorum ve kesinlikle bu
yüzden motivasyon getirdiği ödül bensiz
Daha doğrusu
olduğu zaman
kaynaklarına sahip olduğu kaynaklarıyla
başlıyor Duygu daha fazla oluyor Bir
Defa ve bu süreçte insan fizyolojisi de
değişiyor Çünkü merak duygusu yüksek
olduğu zaman kişi pike ve öğrenmeye
yöneliyor yani ister motivasyonu ile
ilgi duyduğu alanlarda daha fazla
bilmeyen daha fazla öğrenmeye
yöneliyoruz Biz araştırmalar su
gözüküyor Biz ve yapmasıyla davranmamızı
bir şeyler öğrenmemizi şeyler
bildiğimizi aşağıda
görebiliriz dediğimizi yararlı E
[Müzik]
daha
daha iyi yönlendirebiliyor
kullanabiliyorum dikkatimi iyi
odaklandığın için dışarıdan gelen farklı
ulaşımı engelledi bildiği için bu
ba ba ba sizin olduğunu Siz de baktım
yine olan yapabilmek veda ve öğrenme
gibi
bize daha fazla gerçekleştiriyoruz
tek başına değil öğrettiği Zeynep değil
yani uygun yapan kişi zorlukta
karşılaşacak
başarısız olmayacak diye bir şey yok
elbise üstleri bazı şeyler eksik
yaptığımızda doğru sıra şıp işler
Kullanmadığımız başarısız olacağız ama
zorluklar karşısında yılan
göster Göster metin3 de sahip olduğunuzu
hayalleri benim sizi daha kolay
gerçekleşiyor buna bağlı olarak
performansınız daha yüksek oluyor
başarısızlık karşısında
başarısızlık hiç kimse için sevimli bir
deneyim değil oldukça acı verici bir
deneyim Ama ister motivasyonla davranan
yerleştirmesi için başarısızlık Aslı bir
ders oluyor yani onlarda kapasitelerine
ya bu 31 geri bildirim değil mi Yanlış
yaptıklarına ne bir dahaki sefer niye
nasıl giderlerse daha doğru
yapabileceklerini ilişkiyi geri gelirim
size ne oluyor size bu
başarısızlıklardan takımda karşılayıp
ayağa kalkıp yürü daha kolay
çalışmak öğrenmek daha
kişinin
şöyle düşünelim
olabilir
psikolojik yaşam kalitesi çok farklı
olacaktır daha keyifli da hayattan
memnun oldum duygular Burası olacaktır
yine psikolojik iyilik hali mi Örneğin
yaşam doyumu daha az endişe yaşamak
olumlu duyguları yaşamak Bunların hepsi
de İslam motivasyonda yol aldığımızda
gerçekleşecek şimdi az önce şunu
söylemiştim bu geceleri benimsediğimiz
değişti yerleştirdiğimiz zaman yani
bunlar bir solmaz ama bu bir yani ha
başkası da yatıyor bana benim Bunlar o
zaman oluyor ders sonucu
ihtiyaçlarınızın karşılanması oldu
öbürlerinden birisine göre teorisyenleri
görebilirsiniz bizim ihtiyacımız var
bizim hayatımızda
su içmek gibi
karşılanması gereken bazı temel
psikolojik ihtiyaçlar bunlardan bir
tanesi özellik Yani kendi kararlarımızı
kendimiz verilmesi Daha doğrusu bu hani
Boğazı vermiş dediğini yaparım bir şey
değil ama ne yapıyorsun Onu kendiniz
anlar ve kendim almamış ihraç etmiş
geceler kendi değerlerinden süzgeçler
Biçim şekil almış bir şekilde bunu
yapıyorum ya var bu davranış bir
davranışı kimse istediği için ben eve
doğru bulduğum bir sizin sağ
değiştirdiğim için bunu yapıyorum
ikincisi yakınlıkları destek Yani biz
bir boşluk içinde tozu hayattan kokusu
şekilde bunları gerçekleştiriyoruz
Dolayısıyla ve bir yakın özellikle
Hayatımızda önemli olan kişiler
tarafından desteklendiği mizde
bunlara gerçekleştirebiliyoruz yani
İşten geçirme dediğimiz birtakım
telefleri bir süre her sahip olan hiç
sahibi olmalı bu şekilde gerçekleşir
diğer de yetkinlik Yani ben
yapabiliyorum de bunun üstesinden
gelebiliyor muyuz Bu üçü Ben hayatımın
dibindeyim kendi yönlendiriyorum yakın
ilişki içindeyim destek görüyorum
edebilirim vermişti çalışma
arkadaşlarından destek görüyorum ve bu
iş yapabiliyorum
hayatımdan Ben size bir örnek vermek
isterim benim babama
e Okul yani çok küçükken hayatımda ilk
Anılar Bunlar çok küçüktüm 6-7
yaşlarındayken bunları hatırlıyorum hem
hem de ders çalış yani Hem okuyordu hem
de işte çalışıyorum Gündüz işine geldiği
zaman akşam oturup ders çalışacak
tahtası var mı çalışma tahta
üzerinde çalışacağız
çalışırken Gördünüz işte eve gelince
ders
çalışmak Fikri çalışma ve emek vermesi
gördüm Çok önemli olduğunu düşünüyorum
ama olduğunu düşündüğü bir faaliyeti bir
[Müzik]
en iyi sokak Bütün bunlara rağmen Yani
çalışan bir zor olabilirsiniz emekli
silebilirsiniz bu başarısız ol hayatta
hiç başarısız takmayacaksın anlamına
gelmiyor
ilk yarısını Ankara'da Okulu ikinci
yarısında Doğu Anadolu'da Küçük bir
şehirde oldu oradan mezun oldum Daha
sonra bunun için İstanbul'a geldi küçük
yediler bu fikrimizi kazandım bilmiyorum
İstanbul'a geldiğinde şöyle bir sonuca
vardım çocuk
geldim Burada başarılı olamaz yani
başladı sınıftayım ve
öğrenci olarak w56h
o Ayfer dost Didem Ocak ol dedim ben o
kadar şaşırdım ki arkadaşlık vardı
Benden bahsediyor diye evet olmuş Sokak
benim için bu önemli bir sıçrama noktası
oldu Daha önce de başarılı öğrenci
almaya gittim İstanbul'a geldim hadi
falan o benim için gerçekten bir roketi
ateşledi Ne oldu oradaki olan şey
yapabiliyorum ben yapabiliyorum ve ondan
sonra inanıp ve bütün işte şey açıldı
açıldı
rahatladım kendime güvendim ve o dönemin
sonunda daha 3 ay önce doğrudan o
Anadolu'dan İstanbul'a geldi öğrenci
olarak Size birkaç taktik çok zorlu
takdirde takdirname alan bir öğrenci
güç
ihtiyacı tekrar vurgulamak istiyorum bir
şeyi bizim Rıza göstermez yani
çocuklarımızı iletişimimiz de
çalışanlarımız öğrencilerimizi yeşil
Evet şimdi bu çok önemli onların
fikirlerine saygı göstermek onları
seçenek sunmak gibi karar verme ve bir
şey zorunlulukla yapılacaksa bize Bunun
açıklamasını yapmak onlar içine bazı
değerlerin önem Fikri milletlerin ister
yaşındasın kolaylaştırır Burger destek
olmak
için de
[Müzik]
bu
İstanbul Yavuz insanların heyecanlıyım
olsa kolay harekete geçiyor ama eğer bir
fikir Bir Hayal bir hedef nasıl oraya
ulaşılacak konusunda iyi bir planlamaya
sahip değilse Bu ne kadar ya baştan
güzel bir fikirleri beyaz öyle hedef
olarak ortaya çıkmış olursa uyku
yüzünü hayvan Dolayısıyla hayatınızda
önemli bir gelişim ve değişim
gerçekleşti ve kudretin kaybolacak O
zaman ne yapacağız
inanamayacağınız ve bu bir anlamayı adım
adım yıllar gerçekleştireceğiz
belirli
motivasyon
kaynakları harekete geçirir Ben zaten
hani çok yakında olduğu için kolayca
gerçekleşecektir Ama özellikle uzun
model iyileştirici Çünkü çok uzakta
örneği öğrencinin ya dokuz seviyorum
üniversite sınavına gelir
[Müzik]
gerçekleştirilmesi için
zorlu
bir de şöyle bir şey var mı
o zaten bu kadar zor olduğu için doktora
gidiyor
hareket
ediyorum Nerede yani bu
nerede ben zorlanacağı ve buraları nasıl
aşabilirim bunları hazırlıklı olmak için
ben sürpriz olmasın birisi Ah
üniversiteye hazırlanan bir öğrenci için
İşyerindeki sizi aşamaları geçmesi
gereken bir çalışan için kendi işi
olupda daha başlayacak olan sizi olan
kişiler ile arada basamaklar var Selam
bugün gerçekleşti beş yıl sonraki hedefi
için ben bugün ne yapabiliriz bunu
Günleri ayları haftaları döndüğünde o 50
yazı sonraki hedefin bugünkü görevi
nedir Ben bugün Onun için ne yapabilirim
bunu Betty ne kadar planlama ve bugünkü
sorumluluklarımı konusunda bilinçli
olmak Dolayısıyla o uzakta görün hedefin
bir süre sonra söyle benim adam vazgeçme
olasılığını düşüren bir şey yine detaya
giriyoruz Burada nerede ne zaman hangisi
yapacağını planlama yani o uzun vadeli
Hedefte Tamam ara hedefleri var
belirledim ama onları hangi koşullarda
ne zamanlarda yapacağım çünkü orada
şöyle bir şey var Bir şey hedeflediğimiz
sana ya Ne kadar çalışkan bir insanın
olursak olalım bunu diğerine inansak bu
imanın çalışmak bir emek gerektirir Yani
mesela onun için idare irade göstermemiz
gerekiyor Evet
Çalışmak yerine Aslında daha eğlence
daha farklı en iyi şeyler bizi
dikkatinizi çekebilir ya bir ben birde
bir Aslı ilgilenmediğim için bizi ya da
Shrek ve İzmir pembe bir hale geliyor ya
arkadaşımız Hadi şimdi kahve için
dediğinde dolayı sizi çevirici olarak
Hani yalnız oraya gidebiliyor işi diye
yapmamız gerekenleri detaylı bir şekilde
planladığımız da işte ben şu gündüz
saatleri arasında bu işi yapacağım
şurada yapacağım Onun yeri dediğini Bu
bir tane plazmayı yapmak Aslında benim
kendime verdiğim bir tane de oluyor bir
sözleşme oluyor Dolayısıyla bu getireyim
kendi kafamda kurtulduk beni çevirecek
olan bu unsurları karşıda gözlerle
olasım daha fazla artıyor dolayısıyla da
yaptım adım adım uygulamaya geçiyorum
bazen sonra performansını
değerlendiriyorum yalnız gitti şimdi
gitti yani istediğim gibi oldu mu bir öz
değerlendirme yapıyor ve yola devam
ediyoruz ne söylemişti olabilir Biz
Yoldayken fikrimiz değişiklik Yani
aslında yaptığımız için der ve onları
uygulama sürecinde O bizi çeşitlidir
veriyorlar Doğru yolda mıyım yani
gerçekten benim sevdin mi yani o süreç
içinde gördüğünüz şeyler ve
deneyimlerimizle Aslında ilk benimseme
ve kabuller ve sürecini değiştirebilir
Dolayısıyla öğrenir burada tekrar onu
kontrol etmek hala bu istiyor muyum
belli devam ettirebilir miyim burada
kontrol etmek için sağlıklı bir şekilde
yürümemizi yardımcı olur yine yani
hayatından örnekler kapatmak istiyorum
konuşmayı ben ilk önce lisans yıllarında
Sensiz yoktu taraftan yüksek lisansını
bu alanda yaptım ve doktoraya başladım
onlardan almak istiyorum o kadar çeşitli
sebeplerle motivasyonum kırıldı yani o
fikir değilim gücünü kaybettim bu
şekilde devam ettik bu
sonra öğretmen oldum ya altı yıl
liselerde öğretmenlik yaptık
Bu süre içinde psikoloji dersi verdim
dizelerden hep sonucu çok sevdiğimi
gördüm
Tekrar Geri dönmeye ve ama dedi
psikoloji ile devam etmeye karar verdim
Bu karar verdim 34 yaşındayım olduğunda
yeşil yerdeydi ve tekrar ikinci yüksek
lisans yaptım ve Amerika'yı doktora
başvurmaya karar verdim artık 37
gelmiştir o
bu hayal en uygun olan Güneş Yani yapmak
isteyeceğim şey yapar mısınız
ayrılmayalım su içinde eli Bana bu şansı
ver gerçekten burslu olarak Amerika'ya
gittim o yaşta
sonra çalışmalarını tamamladım ve
Türkiye gördüm çok sevdiğim şimdi
yapıyorum o kadar siz olarak rahatsızlık
araştırma yapıyorum ama bu
kadar
takip et
367 yıl sonra gerçekleşecek olan
hedefini parçalara bölmek ve Dirayet ve
sabahı bir şekilde ve bütün bu aradaki
ve inişleri çıkışları aşırı
değil
bunları gerçekleştirerek
gerçekleştirdik
bugün
biyolojisi
yaptın mı
[Alkış]
abone ol